J'espère que vous êtes prêt, ce sera là d'une
minute à l'autre, c'est qu'un fusil vous ne savez pas à
quoi ressemble un fusil c'est ce genre
où votre truc et votre arme pour le mien mais je
suppose que nous avons tous les deux fait des armes maintenant je viens de le
faire  Je ne sais pas que c'est ça,
je le vois en toi, j'ai peur de la jalousie, de la
trahison,
c'est tout ce que tu nettoies de l'
humain,
tu sais qu'ils m'ont dit que vous étiez des
connards vaniteux, mais ce n'est pas vrai
du tout
mec, j'utilise mon mauvais salut, vraiment  rapide à
défaut sur
je
alors qu'est-ce que sauver la galaxie à nouveau oui
nous allons vraiment pouvoir augmenter
notre prix si avec deux fois la galaxie Davis
ouais
vous
vous réveillez
ouais
parfois la chose que vous cherchez
toute votre vie buvez là  à tes côtés
tout le long tu es juste là tout ce que tu fais
c'est crier dessus
pas avec les familles
écoute peut-être
après toutes ces années je t'ai trouvé et
qui diable es-tu je suis ton père
toi